the leaders of the house insurance
committee will meet today to discuss the
Durham report's findings after John
Durham testified before the house
Judiciary Committee revealing that the
FBI ignored Hillary Clinton's plan to
link Trump to Russia during the 2016
election Mr Durham in the summer of 2016
did our government receive intelligence
that suggested secretary Clinton had
approved a plan to tide president Trump
to Russia yes was that intelligence
important enough for director Brennan to
go brief the president of the United
States the vice president of the United
States the Attorney General of the
United States and the director of the
FBI yes and was that intelligence put
then into a memorandum a referral
memorandum yes and was that memorandum
then given to director Comey and agent
strzok that's who was addressed to yes
Andrew sits on the house Judiciary
Committee and was in that hearing
yesterday Anne joins us this morning
Congressman good morning to you
good morning it's great to be with you A
lot happened during that six hour
testimony that you were a part of so
tell us your top takeaway
my top takeaway is and as I mentioned
there at the hearing and there was a lot
of important takeaways but most
important is the FBI is supposedly
exists and is there to protect American
citizens and right now American citizens
need protection from the FBI my second
takeaway is that the few changes that
they have made is not enough we need an
FBI that we had for Generations that we
can trust that we know is objective that
we know is non-political non-politicized
that is non-weaponized that isn't
corrupt that doesn't use bad sources I
mean just think of what really struck me
among many things that did was the FBI
was using Just One Source I'll mention
dechenko this this individual is a
foreign agent a bad guy not only were
they relying on his information which
was a complete lie and never happened
what he said false information Nation
but they were paying him for this so
they're taking American tax dollars and
I always think of working people how
they must feel as they work their butt
off to try to make a living used to pay
off this guy just to get information
that they never verified and they kind
of knew wasn't true but they were so
politicized and so wanted to get Trump
they went with it anyway that's
unbelievable for the Department of
Justice and the Federal Bureau of
Investigation we need major
reorganization there were a lot of
notable moments yesterday one of the
biggest mic drop moments occurred
between this exchange between
congressman Adam Schiff and Mr Durham
watch
Don Jr was informed that a Russian
official was offering the Trump campaign
quote very high level insensitive
information unquote that would be
incriminating if Hillary Clinton was
part of quote Russia and its government
support of Mr Trump aware of that sure
people get phone calls all the time from
individuals who claim to have
information like that really the son of
a presidential candidate gets calls all
the time from before in government
offering dirt on their important
opponent is that what you're saying I
don't think this is unique in your
experience wow wow Durham of course
referring to shift getting punked
basically by Russian comedians promising
dirt on Donald Trump but generally how
embarrassing and completely not
self-aware was Adam Schiff yesterday and
all the Democrats quite frankly on that
panel even before shift was censured
well that's the point I mean there's a
real problem
um I believe with their party and it's
greater than just one political party
versus another they have a philosophy
and the philosophy is what applies for
me
does never apply to you so you know
whether it's gun charges in the case of
the president and Son Hunter Biden
whether it is in you know the misuse of
the FBI and what they've done and they
they have actually done much worse or
more corrupt more involved with the
activities that were inappropriate and
illegal then president Trump ever was
the reality is and I know whether you
like Trump or not it's not the issue
here the reality is he was telling the
truth the real deal and you know what
else bothers me and you know you always
hear that term the Deep State and God
you hope it's not true in America we've
got a deep State 100 really seriously
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
it means Lee Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis